ah oui et parfois ça peut être un peu
négatif aussi
il est beau Mathieu entre lui par
exemple Benoît Dubois ou gumanos ah non
Mathieu Delormeau
les mails de côté pour le crever du
moins je dirais pas non à vous diriez
pas non d'accord il pourrait vous plaire
vous n'êtes pas sans sable insensible
aux charmes de matou il est sexy il est
classe d'accord ça il faut reconnaître
et on termine avec la chose que vous
diriez à Mathieu Delormeau du coup si
vous étiez seul avec lui coincé dans un
ascenseur à Mathieu de leur nom en bas
de ses yeux je parlerai de ses yeux à
Mathieu il a les yeux du prince de
Galles il a les yeux du billiam on est
sur un vrai dossier avec voiture de
normaux
[Musique]
et oui un couple c'est peut-être créé et
pour moi il a pas les yeux le prince du
gars il y a les yeux le prince de Gaulle
c'est très gentil
j'ai l'impression que non non tu vas
trop vite à la maison
[Rires]
non mais non c'est très gentil après
tu vas pas venir à la maison je vais te
raconter l'histoire
bonjour
Est-ce que sois gentil Mathieu tu fais
vraiment c'est combien de temps sur une
île déserte pour traquer ah non mais sur
une île déserte il est pas il est beau
gosse oui il est plutôt beau gosse il
est très drôle il est brillant il est
cultivé là comme ça dans la ville j'ai
pas du tout de
[Rires]
blague à part moi je lui ai dit à
Mathieu le deuxième jour dans les loges
parce qu'on parlait des âges etc je lui
avais dit pour son âge c'était un très
très belle objet
non mais je lui ai dit tu peux confirmer
quand même c'est très gentil mais non
c'est toujours les gens qui veulent te
choper que tu souhaites pas choper ce
qui veut choper que tu peux pas choper
tu veux choper
les gens musclés j'aime l'argent et le
pouvoir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si vraiment tu as pas le choix sinon
toute ta famille brûle un mec
dégueulasse pas pour toi pour toi à une
fille dégueulasse ou un mec très très
beau
[Applaudissements]
on est en 2002 là c'est un truc de ouf
là sans déconner là les beatbox arrivent
là c'est un truc de fou quoi non non non
franchement non la vérité pose une autre
question ça veut dire non c'était pas
question parce que non parce que dans ta
question c'était quoi
sinon toute ta famille meurt d'un coup
chaque quelqu'un un très beau garçon ou
une fille mais immonde
on est sûr qu'elle fera pas de mal
heur
il me reste plus beaucoup ça compte non
mais toi tu es magnifique
nous deux jours ensemble je vous laisse
pas 48 heures
on sait jamais laisser 48 heures une
petite allumeuse vous tournez autour
non non Daniel ça va arriver
ça va arriver Daniel ça va arriver je
sais pas quand mais ça va arriver
à la maison elle m'a attendu gentiment
en bas et vous avez jamais
[Applaudissements]
vous faites erreur
non mais elle est venue à la maison elle
était en bas elle était assise elle
m'attendait très bien
regardez-moi ça dire un coton-tige
j'ai envie de le mettre dans mon oreille
non mais c'est incroyable